Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Bam!
Wie Bruce Lee.
Da bin ich.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal andere Musik machen.
Das war nur zum Einstimmen.
machen wir unsere standard playlist die gefällt mir am besten
doch so schön entspannend
perfekt
Bin gerade etwas verwirrt, warum kackt hier mein Mouse-Sharing-Ding die ganze Zeit ab?
Was ist da los?
Ah ja, jetzt geht's wieder.
Keine Ahnung.
Ha, aber war das nett.
So, Windows hat an meinen Sound-Settings nichts geändert, das ist schon mal sehr, sehr nice.
dass windows mal heute nichts an den sound settings geändert hat max am start mod check
geht schon wieder nett was ist das
ich starte jetzt mal meinen vorschau rechner neu
Ups, jetzt habe ich irgendwas runtergeschmissen. Heck, wait. XDHD.
Das ist total broken. Mein Maus-Sharing ist total kaputt. Ich starte mal neu.
Da ist irgendwas im Arsch. Restart. Aber den seht ihr nicht. Ah, ich habe meine
andere tastatur runter geschmissen okay schon gewundert was da geradezu geknallt
hat ich gerade mal wieder hoch räumen
so dass andere tastatur umstöpseln dass ich den rechner neu starten kann
ist preventing from restart warum prevented hier irgendwas vom restart
safe wie starte anzeige direkt aber nur weil ich krank daheim in wieso sonst früher warst
du auch im stream wenn du nicht krank warst die kommt muss bestimmt mit dem grill was unternehmen
lasst mich raten system die beste software ist aber gar kein linux es ist eine windows kiste
App ist, was ist denn das?
Windows
App is preventing restart, Task Manager
Restart anywhere
Ach, der macht Updates im Hintergrund
Der hat mich nur gebaited
Der hat mich einfach nur gebaited
Der hat geschrieben, dass das
App is preventing restart und in Wirklichkeit
hat er
Updates gemacht
Windows gebaited mal wieder richtig hart
You got gebaited
So, jetzt restartet der Rechner.
So, Passwort eingegeben, zack, Tastatur wieder mal hier umstöpseln.
Ready, exzellent.
So, allerwichtigste vorneweg, Leute.
Ohne geht das nicht.
Arch by the way, Package Updates.
Müssen immer Pleading Edge Package Stand haben.
Kann nicht sein, dass unsere Pakete mehr als 2 Stunden alt sind.
Es muss direkt Buy Release, muss das direkt Bäm, muss das knallen.
Jetzt macht er immer noch Working on Updates.
Ist Windows 10 nicht aus dem Support? Warum kriege ich noch Updates?
Ne, nächsten Monat, oder? Nächsten Monat, stimmt's?
Nicht diesen Monat, nächsten Monat ist es aus dem Support, oder?
Wisst ihr das aus dem Kopf?
Chat weiß sowas doch immer
Chat ist doch
Massive High IQ
Windows macht Windows Dinge
Ja gut, hat Windows so an sich
Macht's
Fünfter, Zehnter, okay, das ist einen halben Monat noch
Ich benutze Windows und Linux
Zusammen
Beste Kombination
so jetzt geht jetzt jetzt geht auch das maus sharing wieder machen wir hier mal
alles wieder auf es und ganzen weeps unter uns können sich jetzt freuen
jetzt habe ich es ja wohl gut dann package updates ich wirklich gut gleich
Reboot. So, folgende
Themen habe ich mir vorhin überlegt. Das ist auch
wahrscheinlich
jetzt erstmal der letzte
Java Spring Boot Stream, weil
dann haben wir alles
soweit gemacht.
Dann bin ich Java und Spring Boot Experte.
Easy.
Ups, das wollte ich
gar nicht.
Reboot
kommt gleich.
Dann kann ich das in Lebenslauf schreiben.
20 Jahre Java und Spring Boot
so lange Springboot überhaupt schon
Erfahrung.
Dann Kotlins. Das habe ich mir tatsächlich
überlegt, ob wir das Ganze dann nicht nochmal
in Kotlin bauen. Aber das Ding ist,
ich muss mich mit Kotlin nicht auskennen.
Mit Java ist ein bisschen auskennen nicht verkehrt.
Wobei, als wäre das
die einzige Sache, die ich je gelernt hätte, ohne dass ich
das wirklich brauchen würde. Also,
warum eigentlich nicht?
Warum eigentlich nicht? So.
Hier Package Updates gemacht. Hier Package
Updates. Was?
keine updates das stimmt was nicht äußerst wir champ da kann was nicht stimmen
aber hier peitsche haben wenigstens wenigstens peitsche update so dass
mama zu was läuft noch terminate tag zwar auch zu uns noch mal auch zu und dann mal
Artstealungs wird immer Updates.
Muss Rolling
sein.
Die machen bestimmt Sprint Planning.
Jeden Tag.
Ja, Artstealungsleute. So aktuell wie das ist.
Tägliche Mikro Sprints.
Ich habe heute meinen DHL-Booten gefragt. Warum?
Du meinst wegen dem, was letztens einer im Chat geschrieben hat, dass sich die Polizei als DHL-Boot verkleidet hat?
Ah, wir haben das aufgegeben, in T-Shirt-Größen zu planen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, in was wir jetzt planen.
Ich plane glücklicherweise nicht.
Zum Glück muss ich nicht planen.
Mein Chef hat mir letztens auch erzählt,
dass wir als Karrieremöglichkeit auch den Projektmanagement
Fahrt haben.
Da habe ich mir kurz gedacht.
Das letzte, was ich machen will, ist Projektmanagement, Alter.
Aber ey, jetzt mal ohne Scheiß
Ich find's ja gut, dass es da solche Infogespräche gibt
Weil es gibt ja durchaus auch Leute
Die sagen, die wollen sowas machen
Aber Projektmanagement
Ist glaube ich das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen könnte
Okay, Reboot
Die können mit vollem Ernst
Über T-Shirtgrößen sprechen
Die können auch Requirements
Taken und sowas
Und was
Die können auch feststellen, dass sie den
Need haben für irgendwie
Ganz ehrlich
Ich kann Projektmanagement Sprache nicht
Aber die ist zum größten Teil ziemlich bescheuert
So
Da sind wir wieder
Terminal offen
IntelliJ wieder auf
so heute steht auf dem programm den kram vom letzten mal kann ich eigentlich wieder komplett
raus meißen weil das ist nicht so verwirrend wird wir machen jetzt einfach high IQ move wir
machen jetzt ein git commit und dann machen wir neuen branch git commit minus genau so muss das
heißen wird geht check out minus b neuer branche und da löschen wir jetzt ein paar sachen draus
das ist natürlich absolut so benannt dass ich in zwei monaten noch weiß was ich da gemacht
habe und dann löschen wir mal wieder ein paar sachen das ist nicht so unübersichtlich wird
So, und
der Plan für heute ist
Wordpad, was ist mit mir los?
The fuck?
Wie komme ich jetzt allen Ernstes auf Wordpad?
Egal, Wordpad.
Dann ist es heute Wordpad.
Meinetwegen.
Wusste gar nicht,
haben die das nicht abgeschafft?
Hieß es nicht mal Wordpad, soll es nicht mal geben?
Ja, da musst du mal irgendwelche High-IQ-Projektmanagement-Leute fragen.
Die sind ja auch der Meinung, dass zwei Frauen das Kind in 4,5 Monaten kriegen können.
Was das wiederum für eine T-Shirt-Größe ist, weiß ich allerdings nicht.
So, also, was heute ansteht, ist folgendes, was wir ausprobieren.
das was wir vom letzten mal übrig haben ein pro metheus wenn man das richtig schreibt um
metheus endpoint für monitoring das muss relativ easy sein da muss man anscheinend bloß schreiben
irgendwie in der pro metheus endpoint true oder so und dann geht das mal ausprobieren weil ein
paar metriken über die anwendung sammeln können ist nicht verkehrt dann wollte ich einmal angucken
FFI C Funktionen aus Java aufrufen. Da rufen wir testweise, ich kann nämlich nur bis 18 Uhr,
deswegen wird das heute relativ kurz und knackig, da können wir nicht allzu viel machen. Mal gucken,
wie man irgendwelche C Funktionen aufrufen kann aus Java. Das brauche ich tatsächlich relativ
oft, weil ich öfters Interop mit anderen Sprachen mache, zum Beispiel mit Go und Go kann man nur
interopen mit über ein C Interface oder auch irgendwas in C++ oder sowas. Kommt öfters mal
vor in c sharp ist das relativ easy mit dll import wie sie in java geht mal gucken wir
rufen irgendeine linux in der inge kölner funktion oder geliebte energie in der geliebte funktion
rufen wir auf irgendwie keine und gett haus nehmen oder irgendwie sowas keine ahnung was
man mal schauen also ich vermute mal das heißt bei java auch ffi ffi steht für wie heißt es auf
deutsch ausländische funktionen interface naja fremde fremde funktionen interface und function
interface heißt glaube ich und vorhin heißt ja so viel wie fremd oder ausländer aus der ausländische
funktionen interface für ausländische funktionen heißt das also quasi sachen aus anderen sprachen
sprachen so und dann kommen uns events an weil wir haben immer noch eine globale variable die weg muss
interface auf deutsch schnittstelle schnittstelle für ausländische funktionen klingt das klingt
schon fast was bürokratisches oder was ich baue ich probiere alles mögliche aus was bring boot
kann ohne tieferen sinn damit ich in 14 tage entwickler praktikum bei mir auf der arbeit
machen kann also ich gehe 14 tage mal in ein team wo java entwickler sind und dass ich jetzt nicht
komplett ahnungslos bin habe ich mir gedacht gucke ich immer spring boot und java an weil ich weiß
die machen da alles in java und benutzen spring gut freiwillig wohlgemerkt mache ich das ja nicht
weil ich müsste und dann wenn wir ganz wild drauf sind heute wenn wir ganz ganz
will drauf sind gucken uns mal wie macht man tests wie macht man tests sind ja
wobei das werden wir nicht machen das wird es weil eigentlich eigentlich ist
überflüssig testing komplett überflüssig wenn man first try alles immer
fehlerfrei macht brauchen wir das net keine dokumentation keine kommentare
nichts einfach first try fehlerfrei für immer also ich denke mal die oberen drei
werden wir machen das gemacht aber in der wir machen es aber in der reihenfolge
als jemand der beide schon gemacht hat es wird sich sehr ähnlich anfühlen
was denn
du meinst du was sind sie scharf macht und java oder was oder
oder was ja gut kann er sein wäre sogar ganz gut
wurde vor kurzem gekündigt und aktuell fast nur gegostet obwohl acht jahre erfahrung ich
würde sagen wie auf dem kasten was software entwicklung angeht ist aktuell ein merkwürdiger
markt vielleicht also ich weiß ja nicht als was und wo und weshalb vielleicht ist eine bewerbung
auch nicht so nennt man das die bewerbung ist nichts wie mir wie heißt das im summa im summa
deutsch wenn was nicht so toll ist keine ahnung vielleicht ist ja die bewerbung nicht ganz optimal
natürlich auch einfach sein dass sie keinen bock haben gibt ja manche die schreiben stellen auf
aus obwohl da eigentlich schon über vitamin b das ganze besetzt ist weil sie
ausschreiben müssen und sowas aber acht jahre erfahrung hat der chat ja schon
gesagt heißt ja nicht unbedingt dass man ahnung hat aber die chance dass jemand
mit acht jahre erfahrung ahnung hat ist doch deutlich höher wie bei jemand mit
keinem acht jahren erfahrung also ich würde mal prinzipiell von ausgehen dass
immer mit acht jahren erfahrung in dem gebiet kein loop mehr ist das ist
ungefähr so wo sich die leute früher in meinen videos immer darüber aufgeregt
haben als gesagt hat jemand der was auch immer was es damals war kot 4 black ops
1 keine ahnung ja oder irgend jemand der fünf jahre schon ego shooter spielt wird
im durchschnitt besser sein als jemand der erst drei monate spielt er kann
natürlich leute immer nein das kannst du doch überhaupt nicht sagen das ist
überhaupt nicht so und es gibt leute sind nach drei monaten richtig gut
welche sind nach fünf jahren immer noch scheiße ja extrem fälle gibt es immer
aber ihr kennt ja diese verteilungskurve im durchschnitt wird das so sein
im durchschnitt wird jemand mit acht jahren erfahrung mehr ahnung haben als
jemand mit drei monaten erfahrung das gibt es das gibt es mehr als genug
aber im durchschnitt sind die leute mit zehn jahren erfahrung sicherlich
knowledgebler
wie jemand mit
einem Jahr oder drei Jahren.
So, Chat.
Ganz kurz.
Kurz Hacker
meinen Modus aktiviert.
Das ist auch immer sehr gut für den
Videocodec. Das pixelt immer so schön auf Twitch.
Ich muss mir mal kurz noch ein Wasser
holen ich habe heute fast den ganzen tag nichts getrunken weil ich muss nach frankfurt fahren
stelle ich mal vor präsenzveranstaltungen die war mein tag naja präsenzveranstaltung ich musste
früh aufstehen und in frankfurt wird das vor ort alles angucken aber das war nicht schlimm
die präsenzveranstaltung bei meinem neuen arbeitgeber sind recht angenehm im vergleich
zudem beim letzten ich bin gleich wieder da ich hole mir kurz was zu trinken
So, da bin ich wieder.
hattest du einen workshop hatte ich nicht wir waren heute alle das komplette team war vor ort
weil heute hatten wir gruppenrunde und auf die gruppenrunde ist der chef von meinem chef dessen
chef gekommen also quasi der komplette it chef und da hat mein chef gesagt letzte woche leute
es wäre mir viel dran gelegen wenn wir alle da sind und so schön schön präsent aussieht also
Also quasi alles nur für den guten Eindruck.
Ja, also ich kann halt nichts zu sagen.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist das Einzige, was mir jetzt so spontan einfällt.
Vielleicht die Bewerbung nicht so gut.
Wobei ich auch sagen muss, meine Bewerbung war jetzt auch nicht gut.
Aber ich kannte halt jemanden.
Das ist natürlich immer von Vorteil.
Vielleicht war es auch einfach nur Pech.
Das darf man ja bei kleinen Bewerbungsanzahlen nicht außen vor lassen.
Wenn man sich 2-3 mal beworben hat, kann man auch einfach an 2-3 Deppen geraten sein, die es irgendwie nicht gehandelt bekommen.
Generell muss ich sagen, dieses einfach sich gar nicht melden, finde ich auf beiden Seiten kacke.
Es gehört sich nicht.
Und noch weniger von Unternehmensseite.
Also ich finde, es gehört sich, dass man auf jede Bewerbung antwortet.
und sei es nur, dass es nichts wird.
Leon Latsch,
danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscription.
Oder Subscribierung,
wie man meinen Englischlehrer in der Berufsschule gesagt hat.
Da habe ich auch gedacht,
ich habe nicht richtig gehört.
Hat irgendjemand das Wort jemals
überhaupt in den Mund genommen davor?
Subscribierung.
ich habe auch schon zehn jahre programmiererfahrung c++ cpil musik
peyton und jetzt jayboss ist jayboss nicht der red hat tomcat oder bringe ich
das jetzt durcheinander ins ziel fiel den kann ich verstehen ich bin auch
übelst der java noob und java ist natürlich nicht größer sie schabt auch
wenn ich den titel vom geschrieben geschrieben habe das ist nur um euch zu
zu bewegen oder vielleicht paar entweder java oder c sharp fans zu träger
kalt ist was macht man dann als projekt manager fände so was potenziell
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was man da daily macht als Projektmanager.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich es nicht machen will.
Ist der Overlay-Chat braun, Leute?
Ist der Overlay-Chat kaputt?
Sagt mal was.
Der ist kaputt?
Der Overlay-Chat.
Warum ist der kaputt?
Oh, ist der kaputt?
Was ist denn los?
Äh.
Irgendwie hat das ein paar Probleme.
Kann das sein?
Ich glaube, das ist Brocken gerade.
Sekunde, Leute.
Okay, Chad, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Sekunde, ich versuch das mal kurz zu fixen
Ich versuch das mal kurz zu fixen
Die haben jetzt ne Cloudflare-Authentifizierung
davor, was halt
ziemlich pepega ist
Was halt
was ist das pepega ist?
Okay.
So, sollen wir mal gucken, wie wir das hinkriegen.
Wartet mal.
Hier ist der Chat.
Äh, weiß ich noch nicht genau wann.
Weiß ich noch nicht genau wann.
So, Moment, jetzt muss ich mal kurz checken, wie wir das machen.
Das muss ungefähr so groß sein.
Hier kleiner geht's gar nicht mehr.
Aber das funzt nicht.
Der Hintergrund ist nicht transparent.
Das ist broken, der Chat.
Was haben die denn da wieder für einen Scheiß gemacht?
Das nervt mich.
Vielleicht muss ich mir ein anderes Chat-Plugin suchen.
Ja.
Naja, da gibt es heute keinen Chat, Leute.
Das ist aber ziemlich kacke.
Das ist nicht Manifest V3.
Es stimmt auch irgendwas nicht.
Ist irgendwas kaputt?
Okay.
Leute, keine Ahnung.
Kann ich jetzt nicht fixen.
Irgendwas ist da...
Irgendwas ist da kaputt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der Chat für Probleme hatte.
Naja, egal, fangen wir jetzt an.
Ich switch ja eh öfters mal hier rüber auf den Chat.
Ach ja.
Okay, dann ist das irgendeine Twitch-Geschichte vielleicht.
Aber es ist komisch, dass es im Browser funktioniert.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt so.
Wir machen das jetzt so.
Window Capture.
Ähm.
Zack.
Wartet mal, wie geht das so, ne?
Können wir das irgendwie so machen, dass das halbwegs funzt?
Irgendwie so, Leute.
Wobei jetzt ist das Seitenverhältnis ziemlich broken, gell?
Wie kann man das resetten?
Wie resettet man was?
Oh Gott.
OBS, please.
Transform.
Reset.
Das machen wir weg.
So für heute muss das reichen
Für heute muss das reichen Leute
Mehr kann ich da gerade nicht machen
Der Hintergrund ist halt nicht transparent
Aber was soll ich machen ja
Es wird nicht aktualisiert
Das ist wahrscheinlich, weil das Fenster im Hintergrund ist
Ich mach mal das Fenster nicht zu
Ich mach nur mal so
Ne, ich hab ja
Okay, jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren
Dann lassen wir das jetzt erstmal kurz so
Scheiß drauf
Das muss für heute reichen
Hast du schon mal mit Geodaten gearbeitet?
Ja, hab ich
Wir haben sogar im Stream schon mal ein bisschen was mit Kartenmaterial gemacht
Und Routenplanung
und
Geo, wie heißt das?
Wenn man auflöst, wie der Ort heißt,
wo eine Koordinate ist oder ein Ort
zu Koordinaten.
Also quasi Ort zu Koordinaten und Koordinaten
zu Ort und sowas.
Ich kenne das
vom Namen her,
habe ich aber noch nicht benutzt.
ok da werde ich jetzt erst mal ein paar sachen löschen nämlich die die wir das letzte mal
gemacht haben hier das ganze mit dem chat schmeißen wir wieder raus mit der datenbank
und sowas das brauchen wir gar nicht ich hau das ich hau das alles wieder raus weil wir uns
heute nicht damit beschäftigen und ich schmeiß aus meinem application gedöns auch wieder das
Zeug für Postgres raus.
Das brauchen wir heute nämlich auch nicht.
So.
Der Rest, der ist übersichtlich.
Den können wir so lassen.
Das ist mehr oder weniger alles.
So.
Und wenn ich das jetzt richtig in Erinnerung habe,
müsste die Anwendung...
Der Chat geht...
Ja, weil Chrome das wahrscheinlich...
einschlafen lässt wenn das im hintergrund ist oder ich das fenster switch oder sowas
des abels suspend pages gucken wir mal
ja keine ahnung leute die wir mal dass da mal das heute ohne chat
Vielleicht muss ich OBS mal aktualisieren.
ja das das kriege ich nicht das kriege ich nicht gescheit gefixt
das da muss das heute ohne chat gehen leute
hoffen wir einfach das nächste mal wieder funktioniert so wenn ich das jetzt richtig
erinnerungen habe dann macht unsere anwendung genau eine sache nämlich per websocket einmal
in der Sekunde hier so eine
Fake Message zu posten
an den Client. Das Ganze
können wir auch
ich mache Visual Studio Code
nochmal auf
schmeißen wir den Kram
vom letzten Mal wieder raus hier
machen nur die Websocket Geschichte
wieder rein
Chrome
Achso
Oh
Der Failed, warum Failed der?
Achso
Okay
Also das Funst
Wir kriegen in Browser
einfach einmal in der Sekunde hier neue
To-Do's gepusht
per Websocket
und das ist eigentlich alles, was die Anwendung
macht. Die schiebt über Websocket alle paar
Sekunden so eine Fake
To-Do Nachricht an den Client.
Alles andere habe ich jetzt rausgeschmissen.
Das einzige, was hier sonst noch
passiert ist,
zeige ich das kurz.
es gibt hier einen kleinen cache weil wir rufen diese fake daten hiervon ab und ich
käse immer wenn die wenn ich die id quasi schon kenne ja ich generiere random id zwischen 1 und
11 jetzt gemacht zwischen 1 und 11 rufen das to do ab davon und wenn ich schon mal was mit der
id abgerufen habt da wird es hier in dem cache gespeichert also cash meint das ist das sind
Dictionary mit ID und Response dazu.
Das ist aber nicht, weil ich jetzt unbedingt hier einbauen muss in die Anwendung,
sondern weil ich nicht unnötig einmal pro Sekunde gegen diese API hämmern will,
nicht, dass die mich irgendwann nochmal blocken.
So, und das war es im Endeffekt.
Es gibt eine Sache, die mir nicht dran gefällt und vielleicht gucken wir uns die als erstes an.
Oder chat mit, was wollen wir anfangen?
Wollen wir uns zuerst angucken, Prometheus Backend oder zuerst wie man Event Handling innerhalb von Spring Boot.
Oder zuerst C-Funktionen aufrufen aus Java.
Könnt ihr euch aussuchen.
Was wollen wir von den drei Sachen zuerst ausprobieren?
Der Cache ist nicht Threadsafe, doch ist er.
Ich kann dir auch sagen warum
Der Cache ist Threadsafe
Weil es eine Konkurrent Hash
Ach Moment
Moment
Der Cache ist tatsächlich nicht Threadsafe
Du hast recht
Der ist nicht Threadsafe
Der muss aber auch nicht Threadsafe sein
Muss er nicht
Weil
Okay
Das ist
In dem Fall ist das Threadsafe
Weil diese Sache wird nur von einer
Stelle aus aufgerufen, nämlich von
Von, äh, Moment, ich bin grad
Verwirrt, nämlich von hier
Aber ihr habt, Chat, ihr habt recht.
Eigentlich dürfte das hier keine Hashmap, sondern es muss eine Konkurrent Hashmap sein.
Nicht Konkurrent. Konkurrent Hashmap müsste das sein.
Ja.
So sieht's aus. Der Chat hat's wieder erkannt.
Jetzt können wir neu starten.
Bam.
Jetzt ist der Cache Threadsafe.
Threadsafe enjoy us hier.
Im Chat.
Funktionen machen. Okay, dann fangen wir damit an.
Also wie ruft man C-Funktionen in Java auf? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wir suchen jetzt einfach mal
was das ist. Was ist das für ein Knopf da? Was macht das? Ach, das ist was ich gitmäßig gelöscht
habe. Wen juckt's denn?
Loading Cache.
Was ist das?
Aha.
Siehste mal. Das hätte ich vielleicht gar nicht gebraucht.
A semi-persistent
mapping from keys to values.
Verlust Automatik bei Cache.
Ah ja.
Ja, das ist doch gut.
Warte mal. Ne, das ist nicht Spring Boot, oder?
Äh.
internal ich glaube nicht dass ich das verwenden will da bleibe ich bei meiner
hash map also wie machen wir jetzt hier ff mit c funktionen in java wie machen wir das
Nee, der extra Library für
Ich brauche keine Library
Um der Hashmap zu ersetzen
An einer Stelle
Ja, ich will die Java-Docs haben
Ich frage mich schon die ganze Zeit, warum das nicht funktioniert
Guck, ich will hier
Drüber gehen, zum Beispiel da
Und will
Oder sagen wir, da will ich drüber gehen
Und will Q drücken, und dass ich dann auch was sehe
Was muss ich machen?
Falls du die Java-Docs in der EDE haben willst
Musst du einmal rechts auf das M
und dann Download Docs und Resources.
Da?
Welcher Knopf davon ist es denn?
Download Sources and or Documentation.
Ach.
Moment, Sources kann man auch runterladen.
Dann kann ich endlich Jump to Definition quasi machen.
Und er muss nicht mehr die compilen.
Das muss einem ja auch mal einer sagen, Alter.
Warum macht denn das das Ding nicht automatisch?
Das ist doch sonst nicht so geizig, was Speicherplatz angeht.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Hast du schon beim Vorletzten...
Leute, es gibt so viele Chat-Messages.
Es kann durchaus mal sein, dass ich was übersehe.
Und am besten ist immer einfach ein AdWoblos dabei.
Spam, dann übersehe ich es nicht so schnell.
Element Information is not available during index update.
Jaja, mach du mal Index Update.
Jetzt haben wir auch Texts.
Ja, sehr, das ist nice.
Das habe ich die ganze Zeit schon gesucht.
Na gut, die Formatierung ist ein bisschen fail, aber das macht ja nichts.
So, und jetzt kann ich auch Send Message machen.
Und jetzt komme ich da auch in den Source Code rein.
nicht wirklich lande auf irgendeinem interface aber immerhin schon mal nicht
verkehrt sehr gut zu wissen chat was gelernt also wie machen wir ffc ffc ich
weiß nicht ob man da und man danach suchen muss mit bis hat er mit spring
jetzt eigentlich nichts zu tun
play um wieder die form memory access war nicht
CFFI mit Java, wie macht man das?
Okay, da gibt es... Interop mit C++ muss nicht sein.
Wie funzt das?
keck c++ ja jr okay jr aber
wieder die pläne seite ist echt hat echt viel zeug taugt diese seite oder
ist das irgendwie generierter müll wird bei blähungen
das ist eine gute seite ok java foreign function interface ok die ausländer funktionen
wolf binary bla bla bla jr works jr jr requires pre processing step during bild compilation
FFI
External Tool.
Was? Moment, warum machen die es so krass kompliziert?
Nein, ich will nicht C++ in Java benutzen.
Ich will in Linux C
Kernelfunktion aufrufen.
Warum die hier was von C++ schreiben?
Ja gut, die rappen das ja auch
hier in eine C-Geschichte.
Das hat mit C++ gar nichts mehr zu tun.
ok also welche also get hostname linux oder irgendwie sowas genau das rufen wir jetzt auf
hier standard lip c ja dass das gut das rufen wir jetzt auf das gibt es auf jedem linux das kann man
also ohne probleme dann ist das auf jeden fall da weil ich jetzt nicht so ganz check ist layout what
ich glaube der geist sagt mal hier also in internet würde ich so machen ok ja in internet
sagt die dll import ja was ich lebe oder irgendwie sowas das ganze wird übrigens
bringen sie nicht einfach den klammer so und dann wird sie dann drunter einfach
schreiben hier extern get host name braucht deswegen ein parameter doch
achso ja dann dann wenn wir nehmen mal was ohne wir nehmen wir was ohne
parameter aber die sind in dort sogar so schlau dass man so schreiben könnte hier
name und was weiß ich in oder sei es oder so ja so würde ich das da machen gucken wie man
das wie man das ganze in java macht ok und success zero is returned on error minus 1
zu tun dann gucken was aber an was sie hier schreiben native methods jv mits
compile code native keyword transforms method into a sort of abstract aha gibt
es dann ist native so was wie dll import
ach ja also im prinzip würde ich dann quasi so was hier machen jetzt haus nehmen aber ich muss
auch noch sagen woher hat sich das holen soll oder also wenn das das wäre ja mal super easy
wenn das findet das so und wenn das so funktioniert mich ärgert dass der chat
funktioniert also hier in meiner vorschau von star schon aber unten im stream nicht
Das ist irgendwie...
Doof.
Systemload Library libc...
Wir gucken mal.
Components needed.
JNI-Elements encode Java und C++.
Was?
Hello World.
Okay, also.
Static.
Aha.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Also machen wir das mal so.
Gehen wir mal hier rein.
Was macht denn...
Was macht denn das hier?
Da habe ich jetzt gar keinen Plan.
Was macht ein Static
ohne irgendwas?
Wie darf ich mir das überhaupt vorstellen?
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen hier?
Hä? Jetzt hat er keine Schmerzen mehr?
Jetzt hat er wieder Schmerzen?
Ne, hat er nicht. Die Idee spinnt.
Das ist sowas wie ein Static.
Sowas wie ein Static Constructor oder sowas.
wird einmal pro laufzeit ausgeführt oder wie lipzee get hostname
hier ist noch mal weiter
wie laut der shared library in der static blog des entschuldigen wir werden
we need it and okay ja das was machen ich will kein c++ gedöns was machen die dafür dinge
das check ich nicht was was zum toll wer soll denn das lesen können ich will ja schon bestehende
sachen aufrufen also so wird es war also so alleine wird es wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren wir
können ja mal hier in in main reingehen wir kommentieren unsere springboot anwendung aus
und sagen jetzt einfach mal get hostname.
Äh.
Achso.
Static.
Das wird jetzt aber wahrscheinlich nicht funzen.
Ne.
Was will er jetzt von mir?
NoLibC.
Ja.
Okay.
So funstere ich schon mal nicht.
Der findet LibC nicht in Java Library Path.
Okay.
Ja.
Komm, wir fragen mal ChatGPT.
How to call
libc
get hostname
function from
java. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Was ist denn JNA schon wieder?
Native
Load.
jna java java native access und was ist jni was ist der unterschied
die den jni nutzt aber manuellen c code oder boilerplate vermeidet
Das ist in der Tat deutlich komplizierter als in .NET.
example with f ne jne hieß das oder neben der wies wie ist der gram jetzt noch mal
jr
ok
public class hostname jody laut leibniz schon mal blödsinn
generate header file
was ok chat gpt
I want to call
get hostname
from linux
standard libc
es ist ja nicht wirklich
so
so, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
warum ich die brauche
ich brauche die nicht
Ich will einfach irgendeine Native-Funktion
callen und gucken, wie das geht.
Das ist nur ein Beispiel, dass ich Get-Hostname nehme.
Das kann irgendwas anderes sein.
So, also Host...
Okay, Chat-GPT
macht wieder irgendeinen Mist.
Also,
hat sich ausge-Vipe-Coded
hier.
Schreibt irgendeinen Mist.
System Load
Calling Native Code vom Java.
Okay, JNA.
Was ist... JNA klang
besser.
Java Native Access.
Ist das...
Superior? Oder ja, hat 8.000, 9.000
Sterne.
Java Native Access
Example getting started
Okay, das sieht schon das okay das sieht deutlich mehr aus
Als nachdem wie ich das mir mit DLL import vorstelle als das andere Gedöns
also dann nehmen wir doch mal dann nehmen wir doch mal jna gucken ob wir das hier ob ich ob
ich gecheckt haben mittlerweile wie man hier so package also sowas wird hier wahrscheinlich nicht
geben oder wird es nicht geben also dann gehen wir wieder auf mail von central chat
muss irgendwelche sachen reinpasten jna
was ist davon ist das richtige dass da aber warum gibt es das gibt es das
mehrfach nett java def jna kommt saniert woher weiß ich jetzt was das richtige
ist ich würde vermuten dass hier ist das richtige weil sun und so aber gibt es
nicht irgendeinen link zum zum repo oder sowas
16 jahre alt
Moment mal, es muss, aber
warum gibt es hier, also
ich bin ja auch kein großer Nougat-Fan, aber da gibt es
immer einen Link zum Repo, gibt es hier auch
einen Link zum Repo, wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel
drauf, ah, Projekt-URL
es ist es doch, das ist doch das Richtige
das ist doch das Richtige
das brauchen wir hier
das brauchen wir
Und jetzt
synchen.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Also, dann gucken wir uns mal hier das Example an.
C-Library
Instance gleich C-Library
What the...
Hatten wir bei ChatGPT
nicht gerade ein ganz gutes Beispiel?
Ähm.
Call
Get Hostname from
Linux
Libc
from Java
Okay, das haben wir auch.
Mal gucken.
Libc Instance Native
Load. Okay, ja, das ist so ähnlich.
also public interface c library externe library monka s was auch immer da passiert aber machen
machen wir einfach mal library wahrscheinlich das native platform ist windows juckt mich nicht ich
bin übrigens auch nicht ob man da so macht lipp c
was
und jetzt c library class so ja das package management ist schon ein
bisschen pp gar ich verstehe auch gar nicht warum es keine gescheite idee und
gibt das von spam hier nicht ich hab ich hab ich hab schon versucht hier maven zeug zu suchen über
die idee aber hat nicht funktioniert ok sind f ok das ist auch nicht verkehrt das okay wir machen
das mal so wie es in dem example ist wir machen zwar nur wie es in dem example ist okay wir
Wir printen jetzt einfach Hello World und gucken mal, ob das funktioniert.
Nein.
Doch!
Hat funktioniert!
Was will der denn eigentlich?
A restricted method in Java system has been called.
Was will der von mir?
Egal, es funktioniert auf jeden Fall.
Okay, das funzt schon einmal.
Ich finde das eigentlich, also das finde ich relativ gut gemacht.
Ist mein Import noch auf die alte Sunlip?
Ja.
Aber muss man auch so haben.
Muss man auch so haben.
Kannst du nicht den Cast entsorgen?
Doch. Den brauchen wir doch überhaupt nicht.
Außerdem
schreiben wir jetzt hier einfach
wahr.
Geht das nicht?
Ähm.
Moment.
Ich bin mir gerade unschlüssig, was ich da überhaupt...
Was ich da überhaupt sehe gerade.
Das ist...
Müsste das nicht Static sein?
Ah, das ist static, weil es ein Interface ist.
Aber Moment.
Ach so, das ist eine statische Methode quasi auf dem Interface.
Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Okay.
Ich meine, das ist schon ein bisschen doppelt gemoppelt hier, wie das geschrieben ist.
C-Library-Instance
C-Library-Class
Aber das ist jetzt nicht so weit
Unterschiedlich zu einem DLL-Import
In .NET würde ich sagen
Also es ist relativ ähnlich
Von der
Wie man das schreibt
also muss ich sagen das kommt man eigentlich mit klar so also das funst jetzt müssen wir
schon mal wie man native zeug importiert probieren wir das ganze mal mit get hostname aus get hostname
so string get hostname kriegt ein character array und eine size t also ein int sagen wir mal size t
ist halt je nach CPU Architektur
anders, aber wir nehmen einfach mal ein int.
So, und das ist int size.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich da übergeben soll eigentlich
mit size. Ach, das ist size vom
Character Array.
Ja gut,
es ist c. Da gibt's
keine Strings
mit embedded size.
Das muss dann so, okay.
Also.
Okay.
Probieren wir das mal.
Wir machen jetzt mal get hostname ohne irgendwas.
Wir machen mal get hostname ohne.
Und dann mal gucken, ob es crasht.
Oder ob der irgendwie meckert.
Achso, er muss was.
Wir machen es mal ohne.
Ohne irgendwas.
Jetzt mal gucken, was er dann sagt.
Dann macht er schon mal gar nichts.
Das ist schon mal gut.
So.
Als Return-Wert kriegen wir einen Int.
so es ist nicht mehr was er sagt ja wie salt minus 1 müsste das jetzt sei es ist
minus 1 haha bei der way ich dachte da muss lip c schreiben aber anscheinend
ist wirklich nur c a lip c geht genauso
gut
Dann müssen wir jetzt noch gucken, also übergeben wir ein String, Name und jetzt halt eine Size,
das ist halt nicht schön, aber es ist halt C, da bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig.
So, also machen wir hier, Name gleich 0w, diesen Host sollte es eigentlich nicht geben.
also mein name und name dort längst bei der way mit oder ohne 0 terminat ohne 0 termin terminator
weil es sonst braucht bräuchte ich ja keine länge als müsste so funktionieren minus 1 und
minus localhost localhost müsste aber doch eigentlich funktionieren hat funktioniert
Moment
Wartet mal
Schreibt es hier das Result rein
Wo ist denn der Hostname dann eigentlich
Achso
Moment
Das ist kein
Ich dachte, das ist so eine Art DNS-Lookup.
Nee, ist es nicht.
Hier übergebe ich einen Pointer mit einer Size, wo er den Namen reinschreiben kann.
Das heißt, da müssen wir jetzt erstmal gucken, wie man hier Pointer-Gedöns übergibt.
So mit String wird das ja an sich nicht tun.
Wir können mal das übergeben, aber das wird so wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Genau.
Pointer.
Pointers and Arrays.
Also ein Char-Dings.
Oder ein Byte-Array wahrscheinlich.
Ein Byte-Array ist wahrscheinlich besser.
Also machen wir mal hier irgendwie ein Byte-Array.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man ein Byte-Array überhaupt anlegt in Java.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
jetzt einmal wo man braucht okay so anscheinend
Ja, ByteArrayNameIntSize oder nennen wir es mal Länge, ja.
So, Moment, aber nicht 0, sondern 512, sollte reichen.
get bytes, ne ne ne ne
kann ich nicht, ich muss
ein pointer übergeben, wo diese Funktion
dann was reinschreibt und dann kann ich es nachher
auslesen
so und jetzt sage ich name
und 500, keine Ahnung
512, so
und jetzt müsste name was drinstehen
wobei mein byte erase war, ok
das macht schon mal irgendwas und jetzt muss ich kann man das zu stringen in byte array geht das
da brauche ich jetzt
java-autos arrays to string expansion
nicht so ganz
ich brauche ich brauche aber
Was habe ich denn überhaupt für ein Hostname?
Hostname ist Stream.
Okay.
Fünf Buchstaben.
Das S, das heißt Stream.
Ja, das ist Stream.
83 ist garantiert das S.
ASCII.
ASCII-Tabelle.
83.
Was ist 83?
S.
Das heißt, da steht Stream drin.
Okay.
java beide ray to string asky asky beide ray by the way containing as charakters
to string das ist doch garantiert schon 8 news trick utf 8 ja u t f 8 geht auch
und der wacht ist aske kompatibel also besser gesagt asti steckt den utf 8 drin
also sagt man einfach new string also sagt man new string name
und jetzt
Ach hier, Char Set
Warte mal, was passiert
wenn ich nichts eingebe?
Stream, Funst
Machen wir das mal hier
Char Set
New Char Set
So findest du schon mal nicht
Ich meine der typ hier schreibt utf 8 das ding ist nur das fund so nett weil man ein chance hat übergeben muss
Moment ich bin ja doof meine güte ich bin im falschen hier
Jura set
what the
was zum
Aber warum geht das mit...
Das steht hier nirgendwo drin, ne?
Dass man hier
ByteArray und dann einen String
hinten übergeben darf. Charset.
Charset ist ein Interface.
Ich hätte gedacht,
das ist ein Inam oder sowas.
Ich checke aber nicht,
woher der...
Ach, Charset Name.
das geht auch schaß set aber so von stars auch das haben wir dann sonst noch hier schaßet
vornehmen ich finde es merkwürdig dass es da kein kein namen gibt wo man wo man hier
weg guck warum gibt es nicht schar setzpunkt utf 8 oder sowas standard schar setz das habe ich
gesucht sie ist die leute jetzt haben auch keine magic strings die action vitrine das habe ich
gesucht so uns sehr gut es gefällt mir also ganz ernst das ist nicht großartig komplizierter als
in dotnet das ist sehr ähnlich ob ich jetzt so was hier schreibe also ob ich jetzt so was hier
mache oder ein dll import hier oben drüber kommt er nur wirklich aufs gleiche raus was ist eigentlich
us asky ja asky halt dass das ganz normale old school asky also so ruft man native funktionen
aus java auf das heißt man braucht dazu diese komische jna lib übrigens mal alles raus schmack
JNA-Lib.
Gibt es nicht sowas wie
Clean Imports?
Optimize Imports, das habe ich gesucht.
Ja, cool.
Das ist nice, das gefällt mir.
Dann kommentieren wir das mal aus.
Weil das brauchen wir für die Anwendung
nicht wirklich das war jetzt einfach zum ausprobieren immerhin wir brauchen für
die anwendung nix warum willst du native dll verwenden weil ich wissen wie
funktioniert ohne tieferen sinn aber ich brauche das relativ oft zum beispiel
und nicht allzu lang her das war aber eine dort net anwendung die hat über
interface go code aufgerufen weil es in go die einzig gute brauchbare web rtc
library gibt
alles so kann was man braucht
olivier stange für den sub 23 jahre nice exzellente
Gleich am Start, wartet mal, ich muss mal was trinken.
Okay.
Wie ist bisher dein Fazit zu Java?
Vielleicht auch im Vergleich zu C-Sharp?
Also mir gefällt C-Sharp
trotzdem besser.
Ich muss sagen, ich
finde das allerdings gar nicht so schlimm, wie ich mir
das vorgestellt habe.
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil daran,
dass...
Ups, Moment.
Das liegt aber
wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil daran,
dass Spring Boot
für alles irgendwelche Annotations
hat, um einem massig
Boilerplate-Code zu ersparen.
Nee, das ist keine Springboot-Annotation.
Ich hab jetzt alles schon rausgeschmissen
vom letzten Mal.
Ja, also hier mit... Guck,
hier schreibst du hin, Enable WebSocket
und unter der Haube
bringt er einen kompletten WebSocket-Server
mit.
Springboot, was das für dich macht und sowas.
Ja, das hab ich auch gehört,
dass Getter und Setter mit so einer extra Library funktionieren.
Also ich finde es gar nicht schlecht.
Man muss sagen, es hat schon viele Parallelen zu C-Sharp.
Aber ich finde, C-Sharp hat noch einen Ticken schönere Syntax,
wenn auch mittlerweile ziemlich rumgewürstet wird in der C-Sharp-Syntax
und da auch doppeldeutige Sachen drin sind.
also dieses zeug mit getter setter finde ich beispielsweise auch ziemlich blödsinnig dass
es keine getter setter in der sprache gibt aber man sich trotzdem darauf verlässt dass die dass
es methoden gibt die get und set heißen da finde ich das in .net deutlich schöner link in .net
finde ich viel schöner als dieses komische stream processing in java zumindest soweit ich es gesehen
habe und gibt es bestimmt noch jede menge zeug mehr aber ich bin jetzt ja
auch kein java pro aber man kommt echt gut klar also es ist nicht so schlimm
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe slim ontario dank ich finde es ab huge
subscription alle katzen besitzer
gibt es gibt es eine runde katze streicheln jetzt für dich so
da hatte ich noch dicke hände leute
ich kann so das projekt auf github packen das sind eigentlich nur ein paar zeilen ich zeige
dir einfach die zwei dateien die du brauchst du kannst du kannst du im wort pause machen
guck mal du brauchst du websocket config die genau so aussieht das ist alles erstmal und
dann brauchst du sowas hier wurde die sessions speichers vom websocket und dann kannst du darauf
zugreifen get sessions und geben senden durch das ganze dann hier raus senden durch das ganze
dann hier aus send message lass mich raten du hast du tutorials angeguckt wo die irgendwas
von stomp und sorg js und topic register send to listener und gedöns geschrieben haben oder diese
tutorials sind plaudert es fakt ich verstehe nicht warum alle javascript sein warum
warum die ganzen springboot java tutorials warum die so plaudit sind dabei ist es eigentlich im
endeffekt diese zwei files ja das alles was für websockets brauchst das ist eigentlich
total easy ja die tutorials die habe ich das letzte mal auch gebetet und weißt du wer mich
tatsächlich auf den richtigen trichter gebracht hat das ist tatsächlich chat gpt gewesen
oder chat gpt cool leute sagen also chat gpt hat bei mir das richtige ich habe chat gpt gefragt
dass ich eine minimal simple spring boot websocke application javascript client haben will
und dann kam das mehr oder weniger eins zu eins daraus ja die tutorials also dass
mir auch schon aufgefallen java tutorials neigen zu ultra bloat kann man über die
arrays pointer entschieden das geht anscheinend schon weil hier unter der haube guck mal das
hier ist ein byte array aber die funktion selbst möchte einen byte pointer haben unter der haube
und diese diese jna also die eigentliche definition von der funktion ist das hier in c
ja kann java aber nicht allerdings mit dieser syntax check dass diese library dass man eigentlich
einen Pointer haben will.
Das ist natürlich in C-Sharp schöner.
Das muss man ehrlich sagen. C-Sharp hat Pointer.
Das ist für C-Interop deutlich
angenehmer. Ganz am Anfang
musste man in C-Sharp noch auch sehr viel
mit hier Marschall
irgendwas, bla,
blub, irgendwas machen. Aber das
ist tatsächlich mittlerweile ganz angenehm.
Also die Websocket-Docs, die ich mir angeguckt habe, waren eklig.
Ja, ne.
Hä?
Add Interceptor, jetzt verstehe ich aber nicht, was die machen.
Aber ich sehe schon, das ist...
Das braucht man halt alles nicht.
Aber ich sehe schon, es ist ein bisschen übersichtlicher.
so also dann chat jetzt probieren wir mal folgendes und zwar events das ist ja so ein
thema wo ich etwas set getriebe bin dass es in asp.net core immer noch keine eingebaute event
funktion gibt ich rede jetzt nicht von events die in der sprache eingebaut sind sondern mit
Events meine ich so eine Art, nennen wir es mal so eine Art In-Memory-Message-Queue, wo man mit unterschiedlichen Teilen der Anwendung kommunizieren kann, von unterschiedlichen Stellen, ja.
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, weil das jetzt ein bisschen abstrakt ist, ja.
Es gibt hier einen Background-Job, okay.
Dieser Background-Job läuft einmal in der Sekunde.
und ich will in diesem background job was machen und dann will ich über websocket an
mein frontend schicken hier guck mal es gibt neue daten und so sehen die aus
das sind ja komplett unterschiedliche teile der anwendung ja es gibt einmal den background job
und es gibt einmal hier dieses zeug was ich um websockets kümmert was auch die websocket sessions
hat diese zwei teile können eigentlich nicht miteinander kommunizieren normalerweise gibt
dann sowas wie irgendeine in memory message queue oder irgendwie so ein event bus oder sowas in der
richtung kann man relativ easy selbst bauen aber dort hat so was standardmäßig leider nicht drin
was ich echt doof finde weil das braucht man eigentlich immer und springwood hat so was wie
ich jetzt gemacht habe ist folgendes ich habe mein background task der läuft einmal in der minute so
generiert neue To-Dos
und dann
geht er an den WebSocket-Händler
und holt sich alle Sessions
und schickt dann an jede WebSocket-Verbindung
eben das neue To-Do,
was dann hier im Frontend angezeigt wird.
Das überhaupt Frontend zu nennen,
ist ja auch schon weit hergeholt.
Aber ich glaube, das versteht man soweit.
Und
wie das hier funktioniert, ist folgendes,
weil ich keine Ahnung habe, wie man das machen soll,
habe ich jetzt mal auf die Variante gemacht,
die eklig ist, aber auf jeden Fall funktioniert.
Ich habe
hier
einen static,
also quasi
eine
statische Methode
in diese Klasse
eingebaut.
Das ist quasi eine globale Variable,
wenn man es so will.
Public static
WebSockets Sessions.
Und hier unten ist auch static
konkurrenz das ist das ist das ist quasi eine globale variable ob das jetzt der
hash map und eine setliste es macht ja kein unterschied
es ist eine globale variable einfach dass ich von einem komplett anderen teil
der anwendung nämlich aus diesem background task darauf zugreifen kann
das ist normalerweise nicht so schön und macht man normalerweise auch nicht dafür
benutzt man irgendwie sowas wie den event bus ja dann sagt man so was wie hier
event bus punkt publish und dann würdest du sagen hier publish und dann irgendwie keine ahnung new
refreshed to do message oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung ja würdest du dann würdest du
dann publischen und irgendwo anders in der anwendung hättest du dann sowas wie hier event
was
Und dann machst du dann irgendwas mit
Sowas gibt es leider in dort net oder das bieter nicht eingebaut es gibt sich libraries das machen man kann das auch relativ easy selbst bauen
aber ich habe gelesen spring boot hat einen eingebauten event bus für sowas und das wollte ich mal ausprobieren hier spring boot
events
Drehung schon wieder
schauen wir uns mal an wie das ganze funktioniert also ziel ist diese globale variable hier weg zu
kriegen und im endeffekt hier zu sagen sinngemäß also das soll quasi weg machen wir das machen wir
so wie ich mir das vorstelle das soll weg und hier soll dann bloß so was wie passieren wie event was
publish übrigens ich bin nimmer kurz das darum wenn das einfach mal um in das
bisschen kürzer ist zu do item ok und jetzt will ich eigentlich nur noch
sagen publish so dass das und und dann soll das hier der websocket händler
mitbekommen der hat ja intern alle websocket sessions und hier soll das in
dem websocket händler soll dann das hier mit dem senden quasi passieren dann ist
auch alles dort an der stelle wo es logisch hingehört
jetzt müssen wir mal gucken wie das funktioniert mit mit spring boot in
disziplin will bis kassin auto use events in spring simple application event
Okay, wir brauchen also eine Klasse, die von Application Event erbt.
Okay, das macht irgendwie Sinn.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, das muss von Application Event erben,
damit Spring Boot das so automatisch Magic discoveren kann.
Wieso haben wir doch? Haben wir nicht?
er macht doch im prinzip mehr oder weniger genau jetzt kriegen wir schon
raus das kriegen wir schon raus
so
moment
hier wollen wir hin also wir brauchen hier irgendwie so eine klasse die
application die wenn das wahrscheinlich muss das application event heißen
dass Spring Boot das Ding überhaupt erkennt.
Gehe ich mal von aus.
Wir kopieren uns das mal kurz.
Ich pappe das einfach mal hier oben drüber.
Application Event.
Custom.
Ja, das New
To Do Item Event.
Nennen wir das jetzt einfach mal.
Zack, zack.
Public muss es nicht sein.
Get Message.
Warte, können wir da nicht
einen Rekord draus machen?
Rekord?
Ne.
Ach, das geht nicht.
Okay.
Rekord ist nicht unter der Haube eine Class,
die nur so tut, als wäre es so eine Art Value,
sondern Rekord ist wirklich was Eigenes in Java.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob man in .NET mit einem Rekord irgendwas erben kann.
Ich würde sagen, ja, das geht,
weil es unter der Haube ja eigentlich auch nur eine Class ist
mit ein bisschen Magic, was
autogeneriert wird für einen.
Das weiß ich
jetzt gar nicht, ob du es findest.
Naja, so.
Jetzt haben wir ein Application Event.
Heißt im Endeffekt, wir wollen hier unten schon mal
nicht Message, sondern hier
ein To-Do-Item wollen wir
hier
transportieren.
Mag er nicht.
Achso.
Ja, weil es kein String ist.
So, und das heißt auch hier wollen wir jetzt sagen...
Achso, Moment, wir müssen das noch injecten.
Ne, was müssen wir überhaupt injecten?
Moment, Moment, so einfach geht das nicht.
Ich habe hier noch nichts zum...
Zum Publischen.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall irgendwas hier, irgendeinen Event-Bus oder so injecten.
Gucken wir mal.
Publisher.
Now let's create a Publisher.
Hä?
Brauch ich nicht.
Ich brauch doch keine extra Klasse.
Achso, hier.
Das muss ich injecten.
Okay.
Also.
Quasi sowas hier.
Application Event.
Okay, das ist das, was ich vorher Event Bus
quasi genannt habe.
Das brauchen wir. So, und das will ich jetzt
injecten.
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Add Constructor Parameter.
Kunst.
Mit dem Underscore hat er nicht gecheckt.
So, ähm.
Ja.
Und jetzt?
Application Publisher Publish Event.
Klingt gut.
Publish Application Event.
New.
To do.
Item Event.
Was? Object Source.
Und to.
Was?
Object Source.
Was will?
Okay, ich muss mir das Beispiel doch nochmal weiter angucken.
Listener.
Implements Application Listener Custom Spring Event.
Moin Leon.
Asynchron Events using an Application Event Multi...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Was ist denn das hier? Event Listener?
Annotation Driven Event List.
Okay, da kann man einfach
Add Event List noch dran schreiben.
Das ist natürlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Okay, dann probieren wir das mal auch so.
Hier wird das jetzt...
Moment, was eigentlich...
Was will der da eigentlich?
Bis...
Ach so, die übergeben immer,
wer das Event ausgelöst hat.
Deswegen auch Source.
Jetzt habe ich das gecheckt.
Wait a minute.
Was habe ich denn eben?
Wartet mal.
Nee, oder auch nicht.
Guck mal, man kann auch ein Object
Publishen. Man muss gar kein
Application Event Publishen.
Ach, es ist Wrapped. Moment, es wird
für mich gerappt?
Geht das ja noch besser.
Wenn das für mich gerappt wird, dann kann ich einfach
hier New To Do reinhauen.
Zack. Dann brauche ich
dieses komische Event hier gar nicht, wenn ich
da eh nur einfach ein To Do reinschreibe.
So.
zu du item reinschreibe
also Publish Event
jetzt brauchen wir das hier
das da brauchen wir jetzt
und das muss in den Websocket Händler rein
so und dann können wir unseren
äh ne
wir wollen ein
Du du Item eigentlich.
Aber mal gucken, ob Spring das auch so kann.
So, okay.
Wir machen jetzt mal nix.
Das hier kann
komplett
weg. Das brauchen wir
nicht mehr. Wir brauchen keine globale Vari...
Alter, come on Spring, please.
wir brauchen keine warte mal mal gucken ob es bringen selbst so schlau ist warte
mal sekunde
eigentlich sagen
gucken wir mal ob das so schlau ist und das kapiert also wir haben jetzt ja hier
eigentlich alles gemacht es sollte jetzt einmal in der sekunde die message com handling kontext
startet event und kommt nicht ich weiß was ich vergessen habe stuhlmacher dankeschön für den
sub ich weiß was ich vergessen habe component habe ich vergessen spring interessiert sich sonst
überhaupt nicht dafür dass es das gibt also wenn man sich bei 1 gewöhnen muss
was bring ist dass man 30.000 annotation für alles braucht
kunst handling daptem events so das heißt wir nehmen jetzt hier unser web
socket krempe läuft ja nehmen wir uns ein web socket krempe und hauen den
einfach hier rein so und das müsste es eigentlich gewesen sein ihr get sessions
brauchen wir nicht mehr sessions
values new text message genau und jetzt sollte das eigentlich immer noch
funktionieren.
Schauen wir mal,
ob sich's automatisch
recon... Es geht!
Schon haben wir unsere globale
Variab... Das ist ja wirklich easy
gemacht. Das ist wirklich mal
easy gemacht. Also das ist
jetzt echt ein Punkt, wo ich sagen muss,
das finde ich viel besser
als so, wie es in ASP.NET Core ist.
In ASP.NET Core brauchst du für so
ein Kram, entweder musst du dir was Eigenes
basteln, oder du musst irgendeine Library
dafür verwenden das ist nichts standardmäßig dabei was ich eigentlich
echt blöd finde weil das braucht so event handling von einer ecke der
applikation zur anderen ist brauchst eigentlich immer irgendwo mal gerade in
web-anwendungen gerade wenn du halt auch von server an client was pushen willst
Ja das stimmt, ASP.NET Core ist aber auch eine Library.
Also bei Spring ist was dabei, bei ASP.NET Core ist nichts dabei.
Ich denke das kann man schon vergleichen.
ASP.NET Core ist ein Webframework und Spring Boot ist auch irgendwie...
Spring Boot ist ja nicht nur ein Webframework, Spring Boot ist ein Application umfassendes für alles mögliche Framework.
aber es bringt was dabei und als pilot nicht das finde ich doof und das haben die echt gut
gemacht oder sagt man das ist doch das ist doch wirklich simpel gemacht du sagst in deinem
background service in jack dem ema event pass publisch da was drauf und auf einer anderen ecke
der anwendung registriert den event listener und greift darauf das ist super gemacht also das ist
wirklich nice was du hast im endeffekt hast du hast jetzt zwei zeilen oder so mehr und dafür
hast du wirklich auch die sachen überall da wo sie hingehören weil das handling von dem web
websocket sachen ist hier drin viel besser aufgehoben als in irgendeinem background task
bin ich gut das gefällt mir ziemlich gut das ist ja um nicht zu sagen das ist
krieg hunger leute so prometheus endpunkt das ist das letzte was ich noch machen wollte hier
konfirmt in dem einen punkt ist das so
ome toys spring gut schon wieder play um die haben aber verdammt viele guides
und die hat viel arbeitsspeicher hier
in dem man den world of software development bla bla bla bla
adding dependencies mikrometer registry prometheus spring boot start actuator
ob wir es nie was man da hinzufügen muss ja natürlich die was sonst wir gucken
mal ob es nicht vielleicht schon hier wieder sonst da da gibt es doch wobei
die coolen leute das ja nicht prometheus denn sondern prometheus aber ich bin
eher für Prometheus.
Prometheus ist der
Gott bei den Griechen, der dafür gesorgt hat,
dass die Menschen high IQ sind.
Weil die Menschen waren vor Prometheus
total dumm
und dann hat er ihnen quasi den
IQ gebracht.
Und seitdem sind die schlau.
Was hat das jetzt alles hinzugefügt?
Mikrometer.
Aber sonst hat er nichts hinzugefügt.
Configure the application.
Expose. Include.
Always. Ja, okay.
Das machen wir.
Genau, das ist der...
Prometheus ist der mit dem Feuer.
Aber der hat den Menschen auch
irgendwie irgendwas mit Erkenntnis gebracht
oder so. Frag mich nicht.
Mein Opa wusste super Bescheid über griechische Mythologie.
Ich nicht.
Was hat das hier für Schmerzen?
Cannot resolve configuration.
warum warum nicht
ok aber wahrscheinlich weil ich den acto aether nicht habe
Wir gucken mal die offizielle Docs.
Offizielle Docs haben keine...
Actuator.
Größer ist die Schaf.
Komm doch mal, was du machen willst.
She baited.
It works.
Okay, also müssen wir anscheinend doch
den Actuator
da irgendwie reinhauen.
Actuator.
Ach so, ja, das brauchen wir.
Das macht ja Sinn.
Okay, wie geht das jetzt weiter?
Genau, das da muss ich hier in die Vacation-Gedöns da eintragen.
Ah, jetzt gibt es das auch, jetzt wo ich den Actuator hier drinne habe.
Okay.
I'm learning Spring Boot and Java.
I'm a complete Spring Boot Noob.
und habe sehr wenig Erfahrung in Java.
Und ich habe einfach verschiedene Dinge in Java und Spring Boot versucht.
Wie die native C-Libraries zu nennen
oder Websocket-Verkaufsverkaufs zu machen.
Und jetzt versuchen wir,
einen Prometheus-Monitoring-Endpunkt zu schaffen.
oweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweoweowe
Ich kann Teams für ein paar Wochen wechseln.
Und ich habe mich für die Wechseln zur Entwicklungsgruppe für zwei Wochen eingestellt.
Und ich habe geschaut, was sie tun.
und sie benutzen meistens java und springwood
zweiter mensch okay
also will ich nicht der größte noob jemals sein, den sie je in ihrem gruppe hatten, also versuche ich, ein bisschen zu lernen
Spring Boot und Java für das. Ich meine, wir sind nicht gezwungen, das zu tun. Es ist komplett optional.
Aber ich will sehen, was die Java-Mannschaften tun.
Ja genau, dann werde ich ein zweites Wort machen.
However you pronounce it.
No, I'm not a developer.
I'm a DevOps engineer.
Or soon my...
I'm...
No, that's wrong.
In my last job I was a DevOps engineer.
Now I'm a senior Linux engineer.
But it doesn't matter what the job title is.
It's...
For the most part it's Cloud Infrastructure with Terraform.
und gitlab ci pipelines und linux administration
und viel mit developers sprechen, damit ich die meisten der Leute kenne
wir ditz mit dem programm in golds on stream war
never in java only for the last two or three streams
man will try to create the point so leute das mal gucken wie von stars denn also wir
Wir müssen uns nicht angucken, wie man Prometheus installiert.
Aha, hier, guckt mal.
Custom Metrics in Spring Boot.
Wobei, eigentlich will ich keine...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Kann das sein, dass das alles ist, was ich machen muss,
dass es schon Metriken jetzt gibt?
Wartet mal.
Bekomme ich jetzt unter Slash Metrics, bekomme ich jetzt was?
Probier mal aus.
Curl.
localhost 80 in mich ab matrix können wir mehr machen wenn du eine idee für
hast was du in go machen willst was ist denn da der richtige endpunkt
ich habe keinen plan moment actuator alter jeder auf der welt verwendet
slash metrics aber nein actuator prometheus alter okay hier gibt es
zeug ganz viel ganz viel massive high-IQ-metriken
aber ich will ja mal willkommen wir machen wir eine custom metrik
jetzt spring wird special
wie macht man einen eigenen endpoints
so component custom mit okay ich kopiere das alles mal in die main component custom matrix
service counter von micro mikrometer meter registry jetzt wird's java enterprise business
Custom Matrix Counter Singleton
Factory
Manager Service
Interface
Was ist denn go crazy?
Sagt mir gar nichts.
Ach ja, meinst du?
Man kann hier den Pfad ändern
Also quasi
Management
Endpoints
Mal nochmal richtig schreiben
Alter
Endpoints
Access Default
gibt es die path oder web base path
naja kommt wir lassen zwar so standard haben wir hier ein abblick denn das
muss ein public sein custom matrix counter description
Hier kann man das in Krisen.
Dann nennen wir das mal
Custom Metric Name Description.
Ja gut, ist wurscht.
Wir gucken mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Wie geht es denn weiter?
Also das heißt, theoretisch
müsste ich jetzt schon,
wenn ich das hier starte,
müsste ich das ja schon bekommen.
Grab, Custom.
custom da ist es hier ja kasse metric das ist aber auch easy gemacht also wir
haben schon prometheus zeug in internet gemacht zwar komplizierter
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab...
Du hast jetzt zwar das Repo gepostet, aber ich hab echt...
Kein Plan, was das sein soll.
Okay, so.
Und jetzt können wir den Kram irgendwo injecten.
Oder wie?
Da probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Dann injecten wir das mal in unseren Background-Service.
Äh, hier irgendwie.
Custom.
Ne, äh, wie heißt das Ding?
Custom-Metrix-Service.
Ach, ich bin ja auch blöd.
kasse matrix services so ad constructor parameter und nun sagen wir hier einfach
einmal pro sekunde kasse matrix service increments kasse matrix und jetzt sollte
der Kram. Ja, guck, es zählt ja, Leute,
es zählt hoch.
Es zählt hoch.
Das ist wirklich einfach.
Das ist wirklich einfach
und gut gemacht.
Das gefällt mir gut.
Das hat was.
Das hat was. Also ich muss sagen,
mir gefällt Spring Boot.
Das ist schon nice.
Also die Sachen wären jetzt in .NET
und ASP.NET Core wären die aufwendiger gewesen.
Nicht wirklich viel.
Was? Ich kann den Constructor
weglassen, wenn ich
addAutowired.
Jetzt wird es aber super krass
Magic, oder? Das heißt, ich kann das
hier alles weglassen.
Und das
da auch.
Wenn ich jetzt
hinschreibe.
Auto wired, wired, wired, ah ne, at auto wired, hä?
Öh, oder auch nicht?
Was ist verkehrt?
Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Darf nicht finals sein.
also es kann das wahrscheinlich nicht setzen field injection ist not recommended warum nicht
Should you use Autowide in Spring Boot?
No.
Bad practices and inflexible...
Hä? Ganz ehrlich?
Verstehe ich nicht, was sie dagegen haben.
Ob ich das jetzt über den Constructor injecte oder so, ist doch...
Mein Opa hätte gesagt, ist doch Jacke wie Hose.
Ob das jetzt Final ist oder nicht, gibt es Schlimmeres.
Das ist nicht Business Enterprise genug.
Du hast noch nie anders gesehen.
Du meinst noch nie was anderes als Auto Wired.
ja ob das doch das ist doch so auch gut da sparen wir uns ich meine so viel ganz
ehrlich so viel sparen wir uns jetzt auch nicht aber halt ein bisschen boilerplate ich finde
ich finde das gar nicht schlecht mit dem auto war ja das hat noch alles funktioniert
also ich sehe nicht
okay wir fragen mal chat gpt was das dazu sagt ob wir auto ein spring boot verwenden sollen
wir fragen sie können wir fragen chat gpt mal auf deutsch sollte ich
in springwood verwenden oder lieber in jackton über den konstruktor deutsch denglisch
Warum? Was ist die Unterschiede? Ich meine, es sollte das gleiche sein.
Ich bin ein Mensch, der sich nicht nur für die Welt interessiert, sondern auch für die Welt.
Das Piepsen gehört?
Feuerlamm hat kein Bock mehr auf Spring.
I had declared the fields with injection over the constructor, but then chat told me outwired
should be used.
Don't see, why not?
I mean, it's almost the same.
Why
Riot Boiler played in the
Constructor when you can use Auto-Wired?
Don't see the downsides.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung.
Würde mich echt interessieren, warum man das nicht verwenden soll.
Aber gucken, was ChatGPT sagt.
In Springboot
Constructor
steht heute als der bevorzugte
Ansatz gesehen gegenüber der
Verwendung von AutoWired.
Aha. Warum?
Beispiel.
Ja, so hatte ich das ja.
Vorteil.
Du kannst abhängig keinen...
Okay. Verstehe ich.
Ja. Feine. Okay.
Das verstehe ich.
Testbarkeit.
Einfacher zu testen, weil du per Konstruktor...
Okay.
Verstehe ich auch.
Macht Sinn.
Das ist immer Chat GPT ist manchmal gar nicht so verkehrt.
Weil du kannst jetzt nicht in irgendeinem Test sagen hier new schedule tasks bla bla
bla.
Das funktioniert.
Klar, du siehst sofort welche Abhängigkeit Null Sicherheit der Compiler zwingt dich.
kompatibilität mit required args konstruktor von lombok spart boilerplate
was auch immer wir müssen uns definitiv lombok noch angucken heute aber nicht
das scheint ja sehr verbreitete library zu sein oder wie sieht's aus leute seit
hier lombok enjoyers chat ich habe außer dass ich ein paar mal gelesen habe noch nie verwendet
lombok auf jeden fall standard ok also haben wir lombok enjoyers im chat gut zu wissen da probieren
wir das auch mal aus nix da nix da stream oder so über nix da streamen wir was anderes machen als
java die hardcore java leute mögen es nicht das sind aber bestimmt auch leute
die gegen kotlin sind oder wo das alles boilerplate alles java mit zisch factories
managern und services sein muss die nutzen die nutzen interne apis die
wegfallen sollen. Oh.
Okay.
Also,
es ist anscheinend umstritten.
Okay,
Chat, ich bin überzeugt,
dass es über den
Constructor Injection besser ist.
Wir machen,
wir lassen ins
Constructor Injection.
Satzserver,
ja, Satzserver Stream, das machen wir als nächstes.
Ich ändere schon mal meinen Streamtitel jetzt
Nachdem ich offline gehe
Offline gehe, dass ich nicht vergesse
Weil ich gehe jetzt was essen, Leute
Die sind doch standardmäßig private
Oder, Chat?
Fragezeichen
Wenn ich hier nicht private davor schreibe
Sind die doch auch so private, oder?
Oder nicht?
Was ist, wenn ich nix hier hinschreibe?
Ach, die sind protected
Kann ich hier oben sagen, Final?
Da kann nämlich
Da kann nämlich keiner
da kann nämlich keiner davon erben.
Jetzt sind die aber private.
Weil wenn hier Final steht, kann keiner davon erben, oder?
Protected heißt, dass alles, was
davon erbt,
darauf zugreifen kann.
Was schreiben eigentlich die coolen Leute?
Final private oder private final?
Also
IntelliJ hat da keine Meinung zu
Wie es aussieht
Ich bin ja für Private Final
Private Final
Okay
Die cool machen Kotlin
Ja, aber im Böses Enterprise Umfeld
Ist Kotlin noch nicht so angesagt wie Java selbst
Zumindest bei uns.
Aber ich bin bei der Versicherung. Das ist old school as fuck.
Ja gut.
Chatke.
Haben wir doch wieder was geschafft.
Schön, dass ihr am Start wart.
Komm mit.
Omega lul.
Class final oder final?
Final class, würde ich sagen.
sowas wie Sealed Class in .NET.
Aber jetzt muss ich was futtern.
Es gibt Nudeln mit Tomatensauce und Hackfleischbällchen.
Pepo Fat Time.
Dann sehen wir uns im nächsten Stream.
Ich bin auch pünktlich zum Essen fertig.
Bis dann Leute, wir sehen uns. Macht's gut.
See you.